soon really good before the pandemic
started taking a pilates class
consisted of me and three women who knew
how to do Pilates
the instructor always had to make
adjustment check all right let's do that
thing when we hang from a bar and do
jumping jacks and sit-ups at the same
time
Todd here's some crayons
why don't you mark up the wall for me
draw an owl for me
big owl with a lot of detail
our ladies are going to stand on our
hands and put 100 pound weights on the
balls of your feet
Todd I don't know download a Scrabble
app
or leave yeah why don't you leave
that idea best
walking's good exercise walk on out air
yes I see your T-shirt it says I heart
Pilates
hit the road